put pressure on the sun's defense
five of eight from the free-throw line
18 points
15 rebounds let's play 33 minutes
and again hadn't played in a week who'd
have thought that he didn't be on the
floor
after watching that injury he seemed a
little bit more aggressive in the first
half looked like he had a little more
room
but that's why i like that they put him
at
the five to get a look at how he could
play
with a little bit more room a little bit
more skill
and also more defensive versatility
perfect free throw there so he's six of
ten
mark mark spears espn's undefeated
at this point this this trend of them
chanting towards you
when you're the line still hasn't come
to an end
is it bothersome do you hear it and at
this point like
what do you even think about it no uh
it has come to end but uh i think
something's gonna follow me for the rest
of my career
so i just gotta embrace it and uh have
fun with it uh
but at the end of the day i'm just
focusing in uh my routine
my technique and my body uh
and i said as i said he probably is
going it's not gonna stop
so you gotta learn how you know learn to
live with it um
20 000 people yelling one two three four
you know it's not necessary
but uh as i said like i've learned to
embrace like i know it's not gonna stop
you know and that the other day when it
keeps going it's like
it fades away you know there's times
that you know the first free throw i
hate it but in the fifth one sixth one
i'm not you know i'm not getting no
money and i'm just focusing on
what i got to do and uh you know my
routine